In dynamic programming, we always look
for optimal similar substructure, and
try to find the recursive
solution first.
We can gain some insight into
the substructure of the chain matrix
multiplication problem by running
out the expression trees for
a various ways of placing parentheses.
For example, ((AB)C) and
then multiplying all that by D,
corresponds to this tree here.
(AB)(CD) corresponds to this tree here.
And A((BC)D) yields this tree here.
This suggests that we try all
possible binary trees and
pick the one that has
the smallest computational cost.
Starting from the top level,
we would consider all
n minus one ways of partitioning
this into left and right subtrees.
And for each one of these possible
partitions, for example this one here,
we would figure out the cost
of computing the subtrees and
then multiplying them together.
To figure out the cost of
the subtrees themselves,
we would need to consider all
possible partitions into left and
right subtrees in here,
and so forth, and so on.
More precisely,
we'll let c(i,j) be the minimum
cost of multiplying Ai through Aj.
For each way of partitioning this range,
the cost is the minimum cost of
computing each subtree, plus the cost of
combining the two resulting matrices.
And we just want to take the minimum
over all such partitions.
The base case, is the product of just
one matrix, which doesn't cost anything.